i don't know if you have anything
um any thoughts to say on this whole
idea of cancel culture
where people um
a lot of people use it is become
political so say maybe outside of the
world to politics
is this uh uh do you have thoughts about
it does it bother you that people are
sort of put in this bin
and uh labeled us something and then
thereby you can ignore everything they
say i mean stephen pinker there's a lot
of
harvard folks that are fighting against
i guess these set of ideas but do
you have do you have thoughts i think
that we as a culture
are way way way too quick to cancel
uh people and it it's become almost
reflexive now uh you know someone
uh says something or makes an an
offhand comment uh even a mistake uh
there's there's a move to simply uh uh
cancel
uh folks so i think that this uh
quote-unquote council culture uh has
really gotten out of control at at this
point
it's forcing people to be robotic uh in
many ways robots
as i say not now i know i'm venturing
into your
intellectual domain for future robots
watching this no offense
and there are a minute it's discouraging
a lot of good people from
um getting into public life in any sort
of way because you know who needs the
who needs the stress uh of it well in
some sense you're an inspiration that
you're able to
withstand the the pressure the pressure
of the masses
but it is as i said it's a sad
aspect of human nature that we kind of
get into these crowds and we get
we start chanting and it's fun for some
reason and then you forget yourself and
then you
sort of wake up the next day not
not having anticipated the consequences
of all the chanting yeah and we get
ourselves in trouble in that
i mean there's some responsibility on
the on social networks
and the mechanisms by which
they make it more frictionless to do the
chanting to do the counseling to do the
outrage and all that kind of stuff so
i actually on the technology side have a
hope that that's fixable but
yeah it does seem to be uh
you know it almost like the internet
showed to us
that we have a lot of broken ways about
which we
communicate with each other and we're
trying to figure that out same with the
university
the this mistake by harvard showed that
we need to
reinvent what the university is and i
mean all of this is
it's almost like we're finding our baby
dear legs
and trying to strengthen the
institutions that
have been very successful for for a long
time
you